[Música]
economía en directo América está con
nosotros en el estudio Jorge Hurtado
Jorge buenas noches comenzamos hablando
de economía en Estados Unidos porque
dieron a conocer el dato de la inflación
Cómo les fue a los estadounidenses bueno
la inflación ahí se ubicó en el seis
coma cuatro por ciento anual tomando en
cuenta que en 2022 cerró con el 6,5% de
inflación anual Aunque es la menor cifra
desde octubre de 2021 los precios siguen
cediendo todavía el incremento anual es
más del triple del 2% que era el
objetivo del Banco Central de ese país
el índice general de precios al consumo
subió un 0,5% en enero respecto al mes
anterior impulsado sobre todo por los
costos de la gasolina y la vivienda
según comunicó el departamento de
trabajo los funcionarios de la reserva
Federal insistieron en la necesidad de
continuar esta subida de los tipos de
interés para ayudar a contener la
inflación pero expresaron opiniones
diferentes sobre lo cerca que están de
detenerse pero cada vez hay más motivos
para que los funcionarios de la suban
los tipos de interés Durante este 2023
pasamos ahora a Colombia porque el fondo
monetario internacional cerró su
revisión para este país suramericano Qué
dijeron Bueno el organismo proyecto que
el crecimiento del producto interno
bruto colombiano va a tener una
desaceleración marcada en el 2023 por el
endurecimiento de las políticas
macroeconómicas la desaceleración
también de la economía mundial y mayores
costos de endeudamiento en el planeta el
fmi afirma que no se pueden descartar
riesgos internos y que será necesario
gestionar y comunicar las reformas y
políticas macroeconómicas que impulsa el
nuevo gobierno según ellos estas
reformas deben ser lo suficientemente
restrictivas para garantizar la
convergencia de la inflación hacia el
objetivo principal y también la
mitigación de los desequilibrios
fiscales y externos escuchemos parte de
la declaratoria
el objetivo de reducir las dependencias
del petróleo y del Carbón es importante
y hay que felicitarlos por eso y esto
está en línea con la trayectoria global
de reducir la dependencia de los
combustibles fósiles entonces la clave
es pensar en una transición gradual para
que las propias necesidades de
energéticas de Colombia se puedan
satisfacer suficientemente que toda la
generación de ingresos y de Divisas del
estado se pueda mantener y siga siendo
fuerte y pensar en cómo todas estas
cosas se puedan balancear con las
necesidades sociales crecientes en
cuanto a preparar a la economía para esa
transición sería importante pensar en
cómo diversificar la economía pasamos
ahora a hablar de Argentina porque allí
la inflación sí está disparada continúa
disparada Así es bueno el índice de
precios al consumidor mostró como ese
país está al borde de entrar al club de
países con inflación de dígitos en enero
la inflación Argentina llegó el 98,8%
anual en el primer mes del año los
precios al consumidor crecieron un 6% En
comparación con diciembre pasado
evidenciando una aceleración respecto a
la tasa del 5,1% del mes anterior el
comportamiento de los precios de enero
enciende si las alarmas en un país que
el año pasado como Luna inflación del
94,8% anual la más alta de las últimas
tres décadas y con una notable
aceleración respecto al 50,9 que habían
registrado en 2021 para intentar
contener esta salsas el gobierno relanzó
a inicios de este mes un programa de
acuerdos de precios que limitará por
cinco meses los aumentos en cientos de
productos pero los efectos de este tipo
de medidas oficiales son cuestionadas ya
por varios economistas privados
imparable como siempre la inflación en
Argentina todo un tema en ese país
hablemos ahora de la Unión Europea
agregaron entre otros países a Rusia y
Costa Rica a su lista de paraísos
Fiscales Rusia Costa Rica las Islas
británicas y las Islas Marshall están en
su lista de jurisdicciones que no
cooperan en materia fiscal pero en la
lista figuran 16 territorios además de
los cuatro añadidos como Panamá Zamora
americana fiji One Palau Trinidad y
Tobago y las Islas Vírgenes americanas
entre otros el listado se actualiza cada
seis meses e incluye aquella
jurisdicciones que incumplen los
estándares de la Unión Europea en
materia de transparencia fiscal justicia
tributaria o implementación de estas
normas internacionales para evitar la
erosión de la base fiscal o el traslado
de algunos beneficios Costa Rica entra
por primera vez ya que según el consejo
de la Unión Europea no ha cumplido sus
compromisos para abolir o modificar
ciertos aspectos de su régimen de
excepción de las fuentes de ingresos
extranjeros considerados perjudiciales
Jorge cifra del día para el cierre entre
40% y 87% gastarán más los mexicanos en
la festividad de San Valentín ahí
algunos productos y servicios elevaron
sus precios no sólo por la inflación
sino también por el inicio de una mayor
demanda en el mercado por ejemplo las
cajas de chocolate que entre la última
semana de enero de 2023 y la segunda de
febrero aumentaron un 67% su precio en
ese mismo periodo también las flores se
incrementaron sus precios en un 87% y
los peluches en un 45 ambos son de los
regalos predilectos para los enamorados
mexicanos Muchas gracias Jorge por esta
actualización del mundo económico a
continuación el debate en directo
América
[Música]